quand j'étais jeune je détestais l'école
mais j'adorerais apprendre
curieux paradoxe c'est peut-être le lot
de plusieurs d'entre vous et c'est
probablement le lot de plusieurs garçons
parce que actuellement au québec un
garçon sur trois aura aucun diplôme
à l'âge de 20 ans se tue important
d'avoir un diplôme un qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ça
pourquoi la société veut tu un conte et
des diplômes
c'est certain que société du savoir du
ploreau meilleur emploi je peux garder
ton emploi des sites hors un diplôme
s'est pourvue tout est en meilleure
santé
donc vous coûter moins cher à la société
ce pas par pure philanthropie
c'est par calcul qu'on veut diplômés nos
jeunes
puis nos gars ont un problème à l'école
et fille
et puis les gars sont graves un exemple
à l'université 41 % des filles vont s'y
rendre juste 25 % des garçons 1 sur 4
qui a retrouvé le chemin de l'université
est-ce que c'est comme ça ailleurs si on
regarde toutes les provinces du québec
du canada
c'est la même tendance québec et dans le
bas de l'échelle colombie-britannique
dans le haut
musselman patten les garçons réussissent
moins bien khlifi pour des problèmes de
diplomation bon je le sais c'est correct
ailleurs dans le monde mais quand on
regarde le cda les 34 pays les plus
développés de la planète là c'est le cas
dans 30 2 sur 34 fait nommer lille
france et 2 nîmes mexique italie
portugal espagne bon dans tous ces pays
il au japon aussi bout il ya deux
exceptions allemagne et suisse
rim 0 pourquoi qu'est ce qu'ils font
quelle recette qui ont d'après g de
royer qui sommité dans le domaine de
réussite des garçons ce sera une
question de court professionnels y
arrive à enseigner un métier ou gore
avec les échappés avant qu'ils partent
avec crystal bon mais au québec on sait
ça c'est dramatique pour notre société
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des gens ont fait trois
choses importantes
d'abord on met le paquet on met des gros
sous
sur chaque million de dollars qu'on
dépense au québec
notre gouvernement sur chaque million
avant ça on en dépense 1 million toutes
les deux minutes
il y en a la moitié 500 villes qui va à
la santé ont commencé
bon donc mais il y en a 250 milles 25%
qui vont à l'éducation
aïe c'est quand même trois quarts tout
nu soul dans le 25 % qui restent bons
s'occupe d'eux au tout à faire l'eau le
transport l'environnement développement
économique du canton ne me tue pas cru
quand tu as encore au bout la dent
première chose on met des gros sous
deuxième affaire
on demande ou à nos institutions aux
écoles de faire des groupes programme en
roller en m dans all des plans de
réussite des plans d'amélioration des
plantes de 19 ans lui demande de rendez
compte d'avoir des cibles piles et plein
plein de choses
troisième des affaires ont dit aux
garçons on insiste pour l'heure leur
dire c'est important la réussite pour
les responsabiliser
mais fait les bonnes affaires malgré sa
main sur trois qui vous à 20 ans n'ont
pas de diplôme qui sera pas rendu plus
loin son bon j'en rajoute un petit peu
dans les suspensions expulsion d'école
80% c'est les garçons bon encore au
québec
allons-nous en un autre beau record au
québec 46 % de tout le ritalin prescrits
au canada l'été au québec on a 23 pour
cent de la population canadienne mais on
se tape 46% du ritalin et
on dit garde là ça se peut pas au lot
les gosses sont pas capables de
fonctionner à l'école là c'est parce
qu'il ya quelque chose dans le cerveau
qui est mal en ligne et avec un bon
médicament on va régler sur ont prescrit
du temps du problèmes de drogue
bien évidemment illégaux ou batterie
fille là dedans aussi largement
problèmes plus graves ces gars sont bons
tout sur le savez plus plate clos puis
maintenant on savait déjà les autres on
va voir les choses différemment
puis on va commencer avec un petit
exercice mc exercice pour samedi
l'apprentissage puissent apprendre
qu'ils s'amusent et ça va ensemble on
essaie de son à croire que se séparer
mais ça va fondamentalement ça bougeait
plus
donc dans le petit exercice on va
prendre des pères de mots risque
prudence 4 ou maquillage roman d'amour
livre des records
puis on va essayer de dire que tu un
côté qui va gars sont un côté qui va
filles plus d'un risque plus prudents
moi je n'hésite pas longtemps les
risques ségo puis prudence et plus
c'est ce que georges prend les grandes
lignes qui peut avoir des exceptions
fâché vous pas avec ça 4 ou maquillage
ou beaucoup d'exceptions roman d'amour
livre des records
pendant plusieurs années j'ai été dans
une école
les deux livres qui année après année à
bibliothèque battait tous les records
auprès des go c'est le livre des records
guinness puis le guide de l'auto solo
soit 5 exemple à s'en sortaient tout le
temps qu'ils étaient usés à fin de
l'année ça en prenait 2,9 l'année
d'après c'est propre et il vieillit
billets produisent tous les ans cette
fois bitchage coltart ya encore longue
aux filles sécurité expérimentation dont
j'en rajoute pige les cows dans gow
fille pu pense que vous auriez a eu à
peu près les mêmes résultats que moi
coltart y âge c'est le fun
voir abandonner ce je trouve que c'est
un beau coloriage as well
mais dans langage d'un god secondaire à
dire 1 ou 2 go il trouve un corps et qui
c'est comme ça ça s'exprime avec nba
sous les pots pour tous du largage de
secondaire d'ici là vraiment se trouve
pris car aix tente chambily it is wight
au maire et milo le turban hindou duncan
ce soit ça parle du langage de good
secondaire c'est comme ça ce qu'on est
pas le langage est un peu embêté bon on
va voir maintenant on continue
l'école hommes se gagne bbf à willy go
sas tient un gagne je parle beaucoup
secondaire évidemment puis ça va se
garder un territoire en dessous d'un
escalier à une entrée dans l itc à
hosingen de gobi ne gagnes tu as trois
parties d'abord les filles ces
différents défis bbfc quoi bbf besbes
froide pour ton petit bracelet comme
ceux-là avec bbf puis le mot j'en urgent
d'un groupe mais le sort de la fille
avait donné sa meilleure meilleur ami
cet aspire à toulouse voir une veine à
redonner de trouver jouer sur deux
tableaux homicides dont de nombreux crus
mais c'est très bbfc trafic de gaulle
ainsi la gamme de modèles différents
on va voir maintenant je suis de
l'exercice l'école puisqu'elle encourage
ou encore qu est ce qu a craint le moins
entre le risque la prudence et à
l'époque pour la transbaie sûre en tout
cas tribune maquillage peut me cache
encore moins dérangeant ateliers des
records a vu comme un roman d'amour bas
la littérature madame aubin sur le
ruisseau coton entre le coaltar yachvili
8 change coloriage poussage d'un casse
pour notre courir ça dérange et
dangereux bitchage pense plus n'a perçu
c'est encore moins pire antisécurité
l'expérimentation
succès curité gang fouillis puis ordre
une seule chose à la fois comme une star
senghor quand ça commence un d'affaires
pour sal finissent piquante 190 ait
sailhenc sont intactes une fille sait
capable d'avoir plusieurs tableaux en
même temps plusieurs safar être
multitâche deux mondes différents
l'école elle a dû à la journée en
période tu commences à faire don offert
deux français devoir continuer sur
demain après midi plus tard synes
l'école vraiment pris l'option multi
touch une école qui serait très égoïste
du ray en septembre ont fait géographie
en novembre ont fait un match décent
m'ont fait le français l'attention
hyperactivité même chose on valorise
beaucoup la tension entre la malbouffe
l'anorexie il ya une politique contre un
mal bouffe puis l'anorexie ce centre est
soudain petit bureau bon ça dérange
encore un petit peu moins l'école mais
l'autre est très visible puis ça dérange
beaucoup de mal bouffe entre la gang du
bébé est fait l'écho l'horreur des games
est un danger il ya une époque ça se
donner des rendez vous de vos impôts
l'îlot saint-elzéar grand-saint-bernard
serait plus fort donc l'école a un sexe
et l'école c'est féminin
l'école ça commence comme ça commence
avec la maternelle on le faut commencer
sur le banc d'aucun des années 60
moi je suis pas à la maternelle y en
avait pas à mon époque 56 d'internés bon
sauveur mais imaginons un instant une
paternel howard ferrat main ouais on
voit deux faits remontent au week end le
paternel
on va regarder avec des gros chiffres en
sortir déjà on va ramasser des feuilles
vraiment su on voit colossaux dans des
livres ont raconté l'histoire a ajourné
le temps des histoires de chasse
histoire de pêche on reconnaît toutes
les marques de tracteurs on va regarder
les couleurs on va se situe la clé sorte
de tracteurs l'imac d'autres acteurs on
va parler bois chargeuses ce témoin sur
place à près de la cabane à sucre
côté pression va ramasser divers appuis
vos rentrées sopi on va apprendre les
formes avec des tours de vis des teintes
de tournevis aux murs de la classe
réponse à des tirs de tracteurs ont
reparlé le disparaît d'abord dans la
nuit à la maison ou à la flûte à bec ont
valu ce soit dans le tiroir on recense
rire tant atteint la guitare électrique
or des posteurs on vous fait de la
peinture peau à la petite bourgeoisie
pain soupes au départ a souri au fait de
la canette avoir la faire durer city à
peindre accordé dubois paternel on va se
faire des sorties on voit les jeunes
vaches sentir au cachot par les rafales
on va apprendre à klaus et du plus petit
au plus gros avec un set de boxe puis on
veut on veut parler temps en temps ou
six kilos d une demie ou encore saint
size très size et que ça marche encore
il ya des deux parcs abdiqua perd 8
parce que dans le vrai monde on écoute
passé mais très décoiffant crois qu'on a
tout vendu mes tripes ce pauvre est allé
à link guéri je vois ces pauvre est pas
tout
or les apprendront ce beau programme
et plus on va cultiver la beauté d'un
paternel trop bouge pas on m'a choisi
pour une histoire de pirates puis à fin
de l'année le summum de la récompense
on va ouvrir une transmission pour vous
regardez comment s'y faire ça sans white
la paternelle les filles
yvon tu se sentir un peu perdu là dedans
fort probablement ils vont se sentir
étrangères
dépossédé des cultures et vont sentir
ailleurs aux sentiments puis quand on
sent pas chez nous pas d'appartenance
que c'est qu'on fait on attend première
occasion on semble moins durant le taux
de crochets repas fort en maternelle
encore mais l'école fonctionne sur ce
système là tout le temps on est
prisonniers de nos vieux modèles des
années 60 on construit des écoles ça
pressait baby-boom vite ça ne prenait
des bâtisses bon modèle à l'époque c'est
une classe une boîte carrée 30-32
chaises une tribune un prof en avant on
enlevait tribune
mais on a gardé une res se c'est le
modèle c'était années 60 c'était correct
qu'on a développé tout notre système
comme ça mais ça on est prisonnier de
saut aujourd'hui l'autre grince une
montagne de neige l'hiver se tiraient
une balle de neige
je peux avoir un plan d'intervention
on voudrait mettre nos enfants à l'abri
de tout à l'abri de la violence à l'abri
des menaces à l'abri du danger pour
faire une espèce de monde qui n'existe
pas dans une école de 158 qui font du
ballet jazz siphan c'est correct
d'accord avec ça mais dans le jazz ça
clique moyens pour l'ego qu'est ce qu'on
va leur offrir ce aux autres ce qu'ils
étendent c'est de faire du skate cette
fable haltérophilie howard schultz faut
être en mesure de leur honneur de leur
offrir
mais c'est plus dangereux des fois ça
coûte plus cher puis c'est un personnel
qui est tout féminin faut qu'il soit à
l'aise aussi avec ceux dont la flûte à
bec
effectivement c'est le fun mais quand tu
es capable d'offrir sortir un drôme
benvingut des guitares ben tu voulais
gold groupe du louvre grand comme ça
actuellement dans les écoles on a
tendance à faire des expériences de
chimie mais virtuel sur l'ordinateur du
jour canet sur youtube dont l'ego autres
mso avoir du gaz un brûleur 10 éprouve
est un acide ça peut exploser et ce côté
là il perdu l'école évacués dommage
pire je vous dirai à être un homme au
québec qui s'intéresse aux enfants c'est
devenu suspect dans une école pas loin
d'ici
des gens bien intentionnés un bonjour
voisin cour d'école grand monsieur a
qu'une barbe gros chapeau d'un grand
manteau qui est là en cours d'école qui
se promènent puis qui s'approche des
enfants et aux politiques
l'infante police aller voir un psy ops
ou sérieux arrive d'un cours d'eau
autour d'un cours d'école départ on va
voir si conan mulot c'est le directeur
d'école
il était sorti de son bureau pour une
fois il donne en cours d'école police
est arrivée moi j'ai vu des profs des
ducs arrêté d'enseigner la gymnastique
parce que sur le cheval allemand lui
fallait deux fois soutenir un dow
quelque chose touché un élève à part de
se faire accuser de j'ai vu un
psychologue refusé de rencontrer une
fille des jeunes filles tout seul dans
son bureau parce que les poursuites et
menace les affaires c'est pas de roubles
il ya une journée dans l'année pour
donner des bonbons aux enfants c'est
l'halloween 31 octobre
essayez par d'autres temps de l'année
vous allez vous retrouver en prison à
l'université laval
actuellement dans les inscriptions chez
la même chose dans les autres
universités du québec
les inscriptions 81% 19 deviner hommes
femmes il ya 80% de femmes inscrits en
éducation continue ce % d'hommes fait
que l'école de demain et d'après demain
vont être une école à 4,5 de personnel
très féminin jusqu'au 20 mai c'est pour
équilibrer personnel de sierre déjà très
féminin savoir ajouté à la fin à
quelques gourmands peut-être qu'ils vont
ils vont ils vont se sentir peut-être un
tout petit peu étrange et là dedans bon
il ya trop de choses qu'on prend pour
acquis comme la maternelle exemple de
diviser le savoir en matière normand
maurice le père de ses frères disaient
les premiers responsables du décrochage
scolaire ses directeurs d'école il y
avait dissous de mme diallo directeur
d'école il y avait le verbe et sa pointe
chez puisse tester c'est vrai dans le
sens que en début d'année quand tu
donnes des horaires à tout le monde se
divise le savoir l'unef a enseigné ce
roi de france est mieux enseigner les
sciences humaines mais comprend que ça
touche faut pas que ça se parle vos box
et à comines et puis on a enseigné les
maths plus grands signes hafiz et +20
signaux chimiques
attention touche pas au domaine de l'eau
puis aussitôt qu'on a fini d'étudier
qu'est ce qu'on vous demande c'est de
faire des liens dans tout ce que tu as
pris
l'école coûte ça c'est l'héritage des
années 60 d'avoir un prof avec une
classe d'élèves bien un ticket coûte
à l'époque on peut avoir des ipad où on
peut être ailleurs physiquement où on
peut faire plein de choses on est restés
prisonniers de nos modèles des années 60
puis va falloir pas juste demandé aux
garçons de se motiver plus d'être plus
attentive aux falloir remettre je pense
en question la structure pile vieux
modèles des années 60
l'école d'aujourd'hui avait formé les
élèves de demain mais apprend des
techniques puis des conceptions d'aval
hier qu'on est un problème je la vois
l'école d'aujourd'hui comme un vieux
modèle des années 60 qui auraient besoin
de sérieux ajustements puis même on
essaie de faire des petits ajustements
mais avoir besoin de remplacement aurait
besoin d'avoir une auto une auto
électrique
à l'heure où le personnel
on s'approche oui on s'approche du mur
où le personnel est essoufflé dans nos
écoles fatigué puis a perdu souvent le
plaisir
alors où on ne les conventions
collectives les plus volumineuses en
amérique du nord
alors j'ai pas dis lui plaît pas ce
jeudi les plus volumineuses alors roulé
comme son scolaires sont très 113
centralisatrice alors où ça coûterait
très cher de reconfigurer toutes nos
bâtisses comme on le fait pour les
animaux dans le domaine agricole
alors où le ministère impose des visions
uniforme qui descendent au tambour ou le
personnel m
le système tel qu'il est parce qu'ils
étaient levées d'un puits il sent bien
protéger les gens en passant ils
prennent le discours carcéral il me
reste cinq en faire une résidence faire
comme s'ils étaient une condamnation les
syndicats voient juste de solutions en
ajoutant du personnel
il ya pourtant de l'espoir l'espoir ça
passe par des innovations des petites
affaires comme coup de pouce tantôt plus
d'autonomie à l'école plus d'autonomie
aux enseignants c'est là que ça se passe
quand un duo le goût d'aller faire la
géométrie dans le hall go vas-y
cellphone tu vois les yeux des élèves
il donne la réponse tout de suite faux
l'école c'est pô juste une petite
succursale d'une commission scolaire de
ministères faut que ce soit capable de
décider vous ça mais ces budgets ou sa
affection personnelle
il faut donner la chance à l'école de
donner son plein potentiel puis surtout
il faut cesser de croire qui est plus
facile de changer les garçons que de
changer l'école merci